Đi ngàn 1 bài tử mình một sách nhận gấp cho hông gàry quên mẹ trừ kéo dài 1 năm
Còn các bạn pháp trưng pháp trưng pháp lên qua đến việc xử dụng dầu
Và khi đốt ngà, sau cuộc gặp giữa tổng thống đúng năng trăm
Và thủ trường bích cộng o ban tại nhà trắng
Lâu thái này, giễn ra chỉ bài tổng, sau khi Washington áp lệnh trưng pháp lên
Các tập đoàn nắng lượng lượng của ngà là Lúc ơi và RUS NEV
Bôn đe giữa anh hường, có cuộc ra kép tục môi dầu từ hành công ty này
Chào cuộc gặp, ông Obama nói hông gàry không thể cắt mồn cùng năng lượng từ mắt sơ vàng ngay lập tức
Vì không có được biển và hẹn thống lọc dầu của nước này được thích kể cho dầu thâu u răng của ngà
Ông cạnh báo việc dương dập khấu sẽ gơi thích hạnh lưỡng trong người dân và nềm kích tế hông gàry
Ông trăm vậy tỏ thống càm và trên bố, không có rì sẽ được xam sét đặc biệt
Hẳng định Washington hợp gió tình thấy năng lượng lập thủ của Buddha Pass
Không có rì là thành viên của tổ chức hiểu ước mó đại tây dương nà tốt
Và đến mi tròo AIU, lâu này vẫn vui chỉ lập trường thân gà và truy trích về cho con sửa chậu của anh nha
Quân hẹn lại khi Buddha Pass thường xuyên xung lộn về buồn xeo và một số lông mình nà tốt
Nước này cũng được nề sốt đăng cai thậu để bịn gà cho năng này hành hình hay lắm
Theo quyết trên tệ của tế trong năng ngoài hành hình hay tư hung gà rì phụ thuộc nà tối bài mấy tư phần chăm 1 kí đốt
Và tảm mấy sấu phần chăm 1 dầu thâu